Chinas Bevölkerung schrumpft zum ersten
Mal seit Jahrzehnten
sie ist umfasst 40 Prozent geschrumpft
in nur fünf sechs Jahren das gab es noch
nie in der Geschichte
trotz staatlich verordneten
bevölkerungsboom müssen erste
Kindergärten schließen weil deutlich
weniger Kinder geboren werden
ich will nur ein Kind
der Druck ist jetzt schon so groß ich
kann mich nur um ein Kind gut kümmern
Überalterung und massive Folgen für die
Wirtschaft warum entscheiden sich in
China immer mehr junge Eltern gegen
Kinder
die Kleine bekommt von ihren Eltern
alles was Ihr Herz begehrt Bücher
Spielzeug zwei Haustiere im Kindergarten
lernt die zweijährige bereits Englisch
so wurde auch ihre Mama orange erzogen
ihre Eltern steckten ihr ganzes Vermögen
in ihre Erziehung finanzierten ihr sogar
ein Auslandsstudium und doch ist heute
einiges anders die 35-Jährige will
selbst etwas vom Leben haben
ich habe sogar Freunde die gar nicht
heiraten wollen sie sagen sie haben
endlich einen hohen Lebensstandard
erreicht die Idee Kinder als
Altersversorgung zu haben die gibt es
nur bei älteren Generationen
viele von Chinas Millennials sind nicht
mehr in Armut aufgewachsen mit dem
Wohlstand stiegen auch ihre Ansprüche
one shallow leitet eine Bäckerei sie
braucht das Geld um Ihren Lebensstandard
zu halten aus ihrer Studienzeit in
Deutschland stammt ihre brietzenliebe
die lebt jetzt weiter in ihrem Laden in
Handjob ihr Mann ist Beamter verdient
gut und trotzdem sagt one shaolou auf
keinen Fall ein zweites Kind
mein Lebensstandard würde drastisch
sinken
unsere Wohnung ist nur 80 Quadratmeter
groß das reicht gerade so für eine
dreiköpfige Familie wenn wir ein
weiteres Kind bekommen würden bräuchten
wir eine größere Wohnung das ist ein
großer finanzieller Druck
in großen Städten wie hango haben sich
die Immobilienpreise in den vergangenen
Jahren mehr als verdoppelt zwölf Monate
Nachhilfe Musik oder Tanzunterricht das
entspricht oft einem kompletten
Jahresgehalt Kindergeld vom Staat gibt
es nicht
meine Eltern haben mir ermöglicht die
Welt zu sehen
ich hoffe auch dass es mir gelingt
meiner Tochter die gleiche Chance zu
geben
aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass
ich mir nur ein Kind leisten kann dass
die Welt sieht
China führte die ein Kind Politik 1979
ein um das starke Bevölkerungswachstum
zu bremsen erst 2016 waren wieder zwei
Kinder erlaubt seit 2021 3 doch der
Babyboom blieb bislang aus für die
Staatsführung ein Horror-Szenario denn
die Bevölkerung schrumpft zum ersten Mal
seit Jahrzehnten nach offiziellen Zahlen
liegt die Geburtenrate bei 1,0 Kindern
pro Frau die zweit niedrigste der Welt
in den sozialen Medien werden Videos von
Kindergärten gepostet die schließen
müssen
in diesen Kindergarten gingen sonst
immer hundert Kinder jetzt nur noch zehn
erzählt dieser User
China droht über Alterung mit
dramatischen Folgen für die Wirtschaft
Fachkräftemangel in allen Bereichen und
Problemen bei der Altersversorgung
wenn ein Land eine junge Bevölkerung hat
hat es viele kreative innovative Köpfe
bei einer alternden Bevölkerung hat sie
allerdings ein Problem
das beeinträchtigt die Innovationskraft
eines Landes
James lernen in Shanghai geboren
promovierte an der amerikanischen
Eliteunis Stanford zu den
wirtschaftlichen Folgen von
Bevölkerungsschwund seine heutige Firma
ein Reiseportal zahlt Boni an
Mitarbeitende mit Kindern und beteiligt
sich an Kosten für eine künstliche
Befruchtung langen zählt zu den wenigen
Menschen die Chinas Familienpolitik
öffentlich kritisieren
es genügt nicht einfach die ein Kind
Politik abzuschaffen die chinesische
Regierung muss Familien wirklich auch
finanziell unterstützen so wie das
Europa und einige andere asiatische
Länder tun
also ein großzügiges Förderprogramm
auflegen mit Steuerentlastung einer
Finanzspritze und Entlastung bei
Immobilien und so weiter
doch davon ist Chinas Staatsführung noch
weit entfernt eines der ersten
zögerlichen Förderprojekte gibt es jetzt
in Handjob fürs zweite Kind bekommen
Eltern jetzt 900 Euro einmalig
ausgezahlt beim dritten gut 3000 Euro
doch für viele Eltern nur ein Tropfen
auf den heißen Stein ein Kind
großzuziehen kostet ein Vielfaches
hohe kämpft in Peking mit den hohen
Kosten doch für sie ist das das größte
Glück dass die Ein-Kind-Politik endlich
abgeschafft ist Kai ist ihr zweites Kind
er kam zur Welt dass sie bereits 40
Jahre alt war früher ging nicht verboten
zu Zeiten der ein Kind Politik zur Macht
der Behörden zählte damals hohe
Geldstrafen zu verhängen auch
Zwangssterilisationen und Abtreibungen
wurden durchgeführt
ich war 2012 schon mal schwanger damals
hätte ich mein zweites Kind aber nicht
registrieren lassen können es hätte dann
auch nicht zur Schule gehen dürfen
deshalb habe ich damals abgetrieben
die Ein-Kind-Politik habe die Geburt von
400 Millionen Kindern verhindert schrieb
die chinesische Regierung für zautian
hui ein unendlicher Schmerz sie selbst
ist mit drei Geschwistern aufgewachsen
2015 brach sie mit Gleichgesinnten zu
einem Protestmarsch auf sie forderten
wenigstens ein zweites Kind zu erlauben
für China ungewöhnlich in diesem Fall
ließ sie die Kommunistische Partei
gewähren ein Jahr später war es endlich
soweit und bald darauf wurde ihr Sohn
kalkay geboren
das Glück Mutter zu sein wurde mir erst
nach der Geburt meines zweiten Kindes
bewusst beim ersten hatte ich große
Angst dass es krank wird jetzt genieße
ich einfach wie mein Sohn heranwächst
deshalb wollte ich eigentlich noch ein
drittes Kind weil es einfach so ein
Glück ist
ein hui wollte mehr Kinder haben und
durfte nicht
one shallow darf mehrere Kinder bekommen
und will es nicht die Bevölkerung des
Riesenreiches schrumpft
das China seine strenge ein Kind Politik
so spät aufhobbt sich jetzt